professor Yale University which is like
an Ivy League school that people once
upon a time considered impressive but
smart people no longer do is now calling
on fellow progressives to actively defy
federal law by hiding illegal immigrants
his name is Greg gonzalvez he's
supposedly a law professor and yet he
tweeted this recently quote we hide
immigrants from ice if we have to the
professor says this would be quote civil
disobedience rather than eating and
abetting criminal activity Lawrence
Jones is editor in chief of campus
reform he's been following this and
joins us tonight this leads the larger
question Lawrence of why we even
bothered to fund universities they're a
joke but we're getting to that later in
the show to the specifics of this case
how did he express this what was the
response
well I asked a simple question
I am an editor in chief I'm a journalist
this is something that the left said is
being attacked so I asked a question are
you guys aiding and abetting simple
question he and return blocked me and
decided to go after my organization and
say that we should be on the lists for
the Southern Poverty Law Center that
simple that's the fake civil rights
group that gets people banned that
crushes the free speech rights that
people that disagrees with right yeah
I'm familiar with them so he didn't
respond at all do you find in a
meaningful way do you find it ironic
that a law professor would be calling on
his students to ignore the law well we
couldn't find his actual law degree so I
mean I don't even understand how he's
teaching students about the law you know
you know it's crazy chuckling because
I'm sorry what do you mean what do you
mean interrupt you what what do you mean
by that you couldn't find this law
degree well we couldn't find this law
degree we couldn't find a JD behind his
name but he's teaching at the school so
I you know let's have a PhD but it's not
specifically you're not a lawyer he's
not practicing lord we couldn't find it
so unless he asked records that are
being hidden and we would love to love
to see that but Tucker my point is
there's a lot of laws that I don't like
I'm a civil libertarian and I
I want to push the warm drinks that went
after my community I didn't like those
community but I don't get to say VA I
get the harbor in a bit criminals that
just don't doesn't work that way
and so the instead of him answering my
question he went after the president of
our company because he's an old white
man and he didn't want to face the black
man the black reporter that asked him
the question are you aiding and abetting
just a simple question but let's attack
the old white guy that's kryptonite for
a guilty white liberal hilarious right
Lawrence thank you very much good to see
you